[Music]
music
art food
these are my passion you know i live for
this
i'm sitting on centuries and centuries
of history
because i'm italian you know
you have to travel with your eyes and
your ears open
to absorb culture to absorb
knowledge you know and then like that
you
you evolve
milan is a is the door for europe
it's a place in which you know
beauty design fashion was always there
[Music]
i started you know collecting jazz and
once you're into jazz you cannot live
this is my life since i was 14
when my brother introduced me to the
music
real music
[Music]
i was filming the history of
every single person who create this
these are the traces of the past
it's about improvisation but also is a
control improvisation so before
everything you have to know the
technique you cannot improvise to be a
great chef
but if you're a great chef you can
improvise
it's not about how many records you sell
it's about
how good she is it's about quality not
quantity it's like my style of cooking
you know i walk into this place and i
see billionaires everywhere
way she was singing is like she she was
the jazz with
all her imperfections she was the one
who was transferred the biggest
and the deepest emotions
[Music]
this is the place where i coming back
from the restaurant
i'm sitting and decompressing
every single track on in a
in a vinyl you get an idea you know you
open the record you put it together and
you see
and you feel something amazing that can
be
an inspiration you know
to create the future
you have to know everything and forget
about everything
is exactly the same thing about create
cars
or create beautiful suits or design
you have to know your past where you
come from
what the others did it's all about that
and then
you build the future
[Music]
in the journey of creativity
when you you walk
and behind a corner there's there's
something and you fall
down there you see the world from a
different perspective
and you can imagine everything
[Music]
huh